[Music]
when you think of editing in music you
might imagine
auto-tuning the vocals of a pop singer
or modifying the rhythm of the drums
many people don't realize that editing
exists in classical recordings as well
for example watch these two clips of
concert pianist christian zimmerman
playing chopin's palad number one
can you find evidence of an edit
it's not in what you heard but what you
saw notice the change in the bench he's
sitting on implying that there were
multiple takes
[Music]
many listeners have been surprised to
discover that this performance wasn't
recorded in a single take
and one commenter wrote since the chair
was a dead giveaway i wonder how many
clips were actually used to make this
recording
now listen to this track and see if you
can find any evidence of
edits
in that clip everything from the
auto-tune vocals
to the electronic drum kit is heavily
processed
but people are less critical of the
editing in electronic music
so why is there a double standard and
how much editing is acceptable in
classical music
[Music]
first of all why do musicians edit their
recordings there are two distinct
reasons why musicians edit
number one to erase mistakes and strive
for perfection
and number two for stylistic choices for
example
auto tune which adjusts the pitch of a
recording to correct out of tune singing
is an example of editing to erase
mistakes but sometimes
auto tune is used for the other type of
editing and is entirely a stylistic
choice
because this is somewhat of a subjective
topic we invited a group of respected
classical musicians
to discuss their opinions on editing so
the basis of
what we want to talk about today is
everything
um in relation to editing in the context
of classical music
i love being on panels because i feel
like i learn
from everybody so much and probably
won't learn anything from me but i will
i will have
a wonderful time hearing what all of you
have to say
before we dive into the debate on when
editing goes too far
let's cover the history on how we got
here in the first place
in 1877 thomas edison created the first
reliable recording device
the phonograph over the next 60 years
music was stored on discs and wax
cylinders
and couldn't be edited errors were
prevalent because musicians had to
record each piece
in one take for example listen for the
mistake
in alfred corteau's 1933 recording of a
chopin
a2
even without the ability to edit some
classical musicians were critical of
recording
after one 1932 studio session pianist
arthur schnabel said that recording
music was a surrender to evil
a betrayal of life in which the human
being the original
is forgotten in the 1940s the
development of magnetic tape allowed
musicians to splice together different
takes of the same piece
this is around the time that pianist
glen gold enters the picture
unlike some gould fully embraced
recording he even retired from public
performances
at the young age of 32 to focus on
recording
full time he thought recordings were the
future of classical music and claimed
that the concert is dead
but not everyone was as excited about
the ability to splice together different
takes
with each new innovation there is a
period of resistance followed by
acceptance just as schnabel criticized
recording before
other musicians shared their criticisms
of editing here's a book i discovered
called recording the classical
guitar and it says andres segovia didn't
like performances to be
spliced he always felt guilty when there
was a certain amount of splicing because
he felt he should have been able to play
the pieces
note perfect the first time then it says
here
by the mid-1960s this attitude towards
splicing began to change as
artists and producers recognized that
recorded performances were not
obliged to serve as reflections of live
performance
a development which coincided with a
dramatic increase in the facilities of
studio technology for editing
sound just an open question to start off
with
how much editing do you think is an okay
amount
is there such a thing in your personal
practice and
your experience uh as a as a musician
my opinion on this topic is that's you
know minor
adjustments to just erase that little
pimple
um without changing the shape of you
know all the other features on your face
if i i mean if i had my way there would
be zero editing i mean i
have edited my stuff for sure anyway but
it's sort of like the
the the effect of sort of instagram on
on photos
that kind of playing can't be replicated
live and that's also what we're
expecting
because that's what we hear it's a
slippery slope when you try to make
something so perfect and then when
somebody comes to your concert they're
like oh
you know it didn't sound like that on
the recording i think at some point
you will have to figure out what the
line is for you personally i
i don't think you should be playing all
88 keys and then just putting together a
beethoven sonata from those
tones i mean i think that's ridiculous
but that's an extreme
since the 1980s digital recording
methods have taken over the music
industry
what is the process of editing
such a thing for string musicians in
terms of what can be edited it could be
timing to be international
it can be sound quality it can be even
placing in different notes uh bar by bar
note by note i mean
remaster and then you put it through
this program called melodyne and then
it's polyphonic intonation algorithm
you can adjust each note the the thing
you have to make sure of the producer
that you work with
knows what kind of performer you are
in on stage and what kind of
rendition you're trying to get on the
disc so that that trust between i think
the
the artist and the the producer is is
very important
some advancements have been made but
editing remains minimal and
splicing is still the primary tool why
is that
well classical music usually isn't tied
to a rhythmic grid
and the tempo is often bent for example
listen to the slight tempo changes in
johannes brahms's hungarian rhapsody
number five
[Music]
[Applause]
subtle shifts in tempo and phrasing make
it impractical to record and edit parts
separately as a result it's easier to
run larger chunks as a full
ensemble and then use splicing to get
rid of mistakes
so if editing happens less in classical
music than in pop music
why is it controversial one reason is
that pop music is often recorded first
and then performed later
classical music is flipped it was
initially written to be performed
but is now also recorded for the
audience
the classical recording is secondary and
is just a representation of what they
would hear if they saw the performance
live
that means editing out mistakes may
inaccurately enhance the performer's
actual ability
for example one editor on the audio
asylum music board
claimed he knew of a classical album
that had as many as 900 edits
or once every four to five seconds i've
helped
produce albums which have over thousands
of edits classical so
there is this wide range you know five
edits
for one person and thousands for another
so
even more dishonest is the practice of
editing quote unquote
live concerts often they are multiple
live performances stitched together
dress rehearsals and additional audience
free recording sessions
sometimes whole movements from a
classical music cd were never even
performed live
so how does editing affect music
listeners around 50
of people who stream classical music
listen to it in the background
however serious listeners might dislike
that current recording methods capture a
limited volume range
this is fine for pop music but classical
music usually has
wider dynamic swings listen for how the
quiet french horn
transforms into the massive choral theme
in beethoven's ninth symphony in a
matter of seconds
[Music]
naxos the largest classical music label
has considered using different forms of
audio compression
to better capture the dynamic range of
classical music
what about aspiring classical musicians
in classical music there is a culture
around reaching
unattainable perfection with the
advancement in editing technology
that standard has been raised even
higher mental health is a common issue
among young musicians
one recent study found that one-third of
spanish music students have used
substances to cope with performance
anxiety
an increased standard of perfection puts
more and more pressure
on an already competitive field of study
i don't think it's affecting
our industry positively because it's
changing
what is normal because again the most
normal thing is to put on a recording
not go to a concert that's an event for
everybody
on the other hand the prevalence of high
quality recordings
allows music students to learn from the
greatest performers
with the click of a button compare this
to the 20 year old js bach who traveled
250 miles on foot to listen to the
brilliant organist dietrich buxtohuda
the expectation for mistake free
recordings also puts a lot of pressure
on recording musicians
it's rumored that pianist christian
zimmerman did 76 takes
of list's b minor sonata before he was
satisfied
however editing allows artists to better
capture their vision for a composition
glenn gold likened himself to a film
producer meticulously combining his
takes into a unique interpretation
maybe transparency is key by openly
sharing the extent of their edits
classical musicians can embrace the new
opportunities
of modern editing at the same time they
acknowledge that the recording has less
mistakes
than what they would realistically
create in a public performance
i think it's also good to remind at
least myself right
our main audience is not some studio
class at juilliard
it's the general public when we put out
things then we have really tiny mistakes
it's like sometimes
like oh my god i made a tiny mistake
everybody will know about it
that's just not true our main audience
is the general public
as technology improves editing and
classical music may become more
sophisticated
one composer wrote a piece that was
faster than one boston ensemble could
humanly perform
so he had the orchestra record the piece
at half tempo
and later doubled the speed with editing
software
the final recording was convincing
enough that a new york ensemble couldn't
tell that edits had been made
some may argue that with editing like
this we cut out the imperfections that
make
art human with ai generated art the
human element is removed completely
some ai art pieces are very convincing
recently editors at the archive a duke
university literary journal
accepted an ai generated poem or
consider this ai generated piece that
mimics bach
in one survey 50 of people most of whom
were classical music
enthusiasts couldn't tell the difference
between the bach
and the ai
another advancement in editing
technology are vsts or virtual
instruments
these virtual instruments aren't
commonly used in classical music today
but maybe they'll be more accepted in
the future some vsts sound
so realistic that it's hard to tell them
apart from real instruments
and to put this to the test arthur and i
faced off in a quiz to see who could
guess which
instruments were real and which were
virtual
let's let's let's let's start with piano
g chord
play mine
they both sound fake
okay i'm ready i'm ready one two three
three
okay i think we on the same page
cool oh we got it right okay good drums
one and two
[Music]
when i get this wrong i'mma be ashamed
though you can't tell what's a real
drama well i
i hear this shh sound that it's just
played the china the china symbol yeah
vagina
okay let's do this okay one two three
three oh
i knew i was gonna get that wrong that's
crazy let's see orchestra
let's just get it or show
[Music]
no way this is absolute nonsense
i quit this is what should we do
symbol one symbol two i think this one
might be loki easy
[Music]
at this point i'm literally like
swinging in the dark
like i do not know i want to know okay
two
three okay well we are okay all right
this is the first time we agreed
we got it wrong why
why this is
you this game is cheating no no let's do
piano piano
all right all right all right now right
hey no pressure
no pressure but you're making history
here
oh come on come on come on why is it
fairly
[Music]
this one was easy two three
i'm unreal now
what are we doing so now what
um what made you want to do an episode
on editing in classical music what
really
pushed your button to make this whole
episode go
what's interesting to me is that if
you're recording
you're in a completely different
environment and you're performing
in a different way first of all you're
entitled to do
many takes you're not just gonna go in
there play one take and then leave
keep it that in and of itself is editing
because you're
doing i don't know 10 20 30 40 takes
whatever it is
then that's a form of editing already so
if we're doing that and it's a
completely different form
of this art why
be so shy about other edits but at the
same time i recognize that this process
has some consequences as well because
now we're pushing
what perfection is so
later on when you're on the stage
you have two standards that you're up
against the
recorded standard and the stage standard
and that kind of plays with your head
and i feel like that's an interesting
yet um
at times disturbing part of being a
musician
in the studio or on stage so that's why
i was drawn to this
episode
[Music]
a huge shout out to the clyburn whose
mission is to advance classical piano
music throughout the world
for partnering with us on this video
[Music]